Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at how it
is that anyone has blue or green eyes despite
that those pigments do not exist in the human
eye.
Eye color is a function of pigmentation both
at the back of the iris and in its stroma
as well as the density of the cells in the
stroma.
In most cases these factors, and hence eye
color, are determined by genetics with potentially
as many as 15 different genes identified to
date seeming to affect the ultimate coloring
in some way.
However, contrary to what you might think,
blue and green pigment do not exist in the
human ocular fluid or iris.
In fact, only a couple of pigments are involved
in eye color: melanin (brown) and lipochrome
(yellow).
Aside from potential extreme albinism cases,
all eyes have some amount of melanin in the
back of the iris, although not all eyes have
lipochrome.
For brown eyes, there is high concentration
of melanin in the back of the iris as well
as in its stroma.
The result is the melanin absorbing both short
and long wavelengths of light from across
the visible spectrum, with the density of
melanin in these two layers ultimately determine
the shade of brown, which in extreme cases
can appear near black.
On top of the melanin, amber eyes get their
color from the added presence of lipochrome
in the stroma.
As stated previously, blue and green pigments
do not play a role in human eye color.
So how does anyone have blue or green eyes?
It turns out the remaining human eye colors,
including blue and green, are in part a trick
of the light.
With blue eyes, there is a fair amount of
melanin in the back of the iris, but relatively
little melanin within the stroma, making it
translucent, with light getting scattered
around when it encounters this layer.
This scattering occurs more at the shorter
wavelengths of light, most relevant here being
blue, while longer wavelengths are typically
passed through and ultimately absorbed by
the melanin at the back of the iris.
The net result is the eye appearing blue,
even though if you were to dissect the eye
in question, you'd see the person physically
had brown eyes based on the pigments.
This same type of thing is more or less what's
happening in the sky when sunlight is scattered
in the atmosphere, making it appear blue,
even though if the light from the Sun was
not being scattered or absorbed in the atmosphere,
the sky would look similar to the way it does
at night in the day time.
Grey eyes work almost exactly like blue eyes,
with melanin at the back of the iris absorbing
the longer wavelengths, but little within
the stroma.
One of the reasons these people's eyes don't
appear blue is partially due to larger deposits
of collagen that cause a different kind of
scattering that isn't as frequency dependent.
This type of scattering is basically what
is happening when water droplets in clouds
cause them to look some shade of grey.
Additionally, in contrast to blue and grey,
green eyes have far less melanin at the back
of the iris, so slightly less absorption;
they also have some lipochrome in the stroma.
But as with blue and grey eyes, there is little
melanin in the stroma and so a bit of light
scattering helps impart a blue hue, the net
result of all of this being the eye appearing
some shade of green.
Hazel eyes, which can shift from brown to
green, have more melanin in the front border
layer of the eye, and, like green, grey and
blue eyes, scatter certain wavelengths of
light resulting in a somewhat shifting eye
color.
On that note, the fact that these latter hues
are largely dependent on a trick of the eye,
rather than, for instance, blue pigmentation,
is why people with these eye colors sometimes
appear to have a different eye color than
they normally do.
Nothing has actually changed physically in
their eyes, but changing the lighting may
end up changing the wavelengths and concentration
of light getting scattered and absorbed, resulting
in the appearance of, for instance, a normally
slightly green eye looking slightly blue.
As to why some people have two eye colors,
multiple eye colors can be caused by a variety
of things from genetics to various medical
conditions, such as Horner's syndrome and
Waardenburg syndrome.
Regardless of the underlying cause, the individual
in questions ends up with a non-uniform distribution
of melanin in one or both eyes.
In some cases, the individual might have two
completely different colored eyes (complete
heterochromia).
Perhaps the most common cause of this is genetic.
However, other phenomena can cause a single
eye to completely change color, such as inflammation
like that suffered by actress Mila Kunis,
which changed the color of one of her eyes.
External causes include topical medications
used to treat glaucoma, potentially turning
a blue eye to brown.
Another type occurs where only a portion of
one eye has a different color.
As with more uniform eye coloring, in all
cases the resulting eye color is largely a
function of brown and yellow pigmentation
and its distribution and density in the back
of the iris and in its stroma.
Bonus Fact:
The Haskell Free Library and Opera House has
a curious line painted through the building.
What does this line signify?
One side of the line lies in Quebec, Canada,
while the other is in the state of Vermont
in the United States.
Because of this, the building has two main
entrances on either side of the border.
The building also has two different addresses
and telephone area codes.
Further, because of the layout of the building,
it’s jokingly referred to as “the only
library in the U.S. with no books and the
only opera house in the U.S. with no stage”
(the library and the stage are on the Canadian
side, while most of the audience of the opera
sits in the U.S.).
If you’re wondering, people inside can freely
cross the line marking the border, but if
they then exit the building, they are required
to report to Customs, but otherwise are free
to traverse one side of the building or the
other without such notification.
Intentionally built on the border in the early
20th century, the building was placed such
as Mrs. Martha Stewart Haskell and Col. Horace
“Stewart” Haskell wanted both Canadians
and U.S. citizens to have access to the library
and opera house.